[Music]
energetic
so my name is mike smith i work at
pfizer in the uk
and i'm very pleased to be here to talk
to you today um
because i realize that people are lazy
and easily distracted i'm going to give
you the summary of the whole talk right
up front
um i use parameterized markdown reports
with child documents to write up an
exploratory analysis which i shared with
some colleagues some of whom were
quantitative some of whom were not
quantitative
the quantitative guys like the
statistician and the team and clinical
pharmacologists
from my department uh including my
manager there were other
non-quantitative guys and you know it's
maybe unfair to call a clinician
non-quantitative but i'm gonna um so
this report was intended to serve all of
those purposes
now the analysis and and the stuff i'm
gonna show today doesn't show
that data because of confidentiality
reasons
but it has very similar properties but
what i really want to talk to you today
is about cutlery drawers and what they
say about you
now these cutlery drawers are from
people that you might
bump into at this conference and i think
it's an interesting exercise
in how people arrange things structure
things
whether they do it by size whether they
do it by most frequently used the
differences between perhaps
u.s and and european cutlery doors but
here's mine
if you visit my house you'll see my
cutlery drawer my wife will also be very
surprised that you're visiting the house
and quite alarmed that you just want to
see the cutlery drawer
now i did the tidy verse train the
trainer course and
thanks to to greg and garrett for for
teaching on that
and i i'm now taking every opportunity
to have a learning
experience for the tidy bear so if you
take cutlery drawer you might want to
group by type
you want to gather those things together
and arrange and if you could do that
from my cutlery drawer i would be really
happy new hashtag for the conference is
untidyverse
and i'm really pleased the xkcd uh
views the the need for tidiness in the
house in very similar ways basically if
you've got wi-fi and a laptop
you can put all your other positions in
a big bucket marked miscellaneous
okay here's the premise for my talk my
brain
is lazy shallow and very easily
distracted
i hesitate to say that your brain is the
same
but then we had joe chang up here
telling us all that our intuition
sucks so i think some people in this
audience must have a brain that's lazy
shallow and easily distracted
now we're all familiar with this plot
that's from the r for data science book
and it gives us a framework or a
structure for understanding any analysis
and on the not so standard deviations
podcast recently there was a good
discussion about this
and they came to the conclusion that
really this is just a framework it's a
mental model
real data analysis don't necessarily
have to follow all of these steps or
in sequence so let me explain to you
something about my data analysis
and how it works in practice and i'm
sure that these experiences i'm going to
relate
are just for me alone so it's not you
guys you have your stuff
well together this is just me okay
here we go so i go and i get an email
from my colleague who has a link to the
data source
i download that data source i read it
into r i wrangle the data and i plot it
and then there's some time to step back
to reflect on my plot to think about
what it looks like so that after lunch i
can come back
and make better plots and i might fit a
preliminary model to the data hates the
end of the day it's time to go
home so the next day i come in and i
find an email saying that the team has
found an error in the data so here's the
new version of the data
and if your workflow is not reproducible
you're in a world of hurt here
so because i'm reproducible i go to my
markdown
i change the input data i recompile my
report i see what differences that are
i check against the previous version and
we're good to go on
i discussed the findings with my boss i
circulate the report
and my job is done oh wait a minute
did anyone get kind of distracted by the
text and light gray so it's not just me
then
okay the other thing is did anyone
notice that the transform and visualize
bits from the arthur data science
diagram were back to front and swapped
over
cognitive load theory score one
so any six months passed this is not an
exaggeration
i got an email yesterday
from my manager saying you know that
team and the work that you did for them
they're interested in your results can
you dig them out and share them
now if you're anything like me what
happens is
you pop open your your r script or
something like that and you
think what the heck did i do
right to the rescue
for me comes our mark down in notebooks
right
these guys are now saving my life i love
notebooks
thank you ebay and team who are working
on notebooks
and whenever you're writing you need to
think about who is the audience that
you're writing for
well for me when i write a notebook it's
for distracted me
it's the one that is hopping between
activities
not focusing 24 7 on my nice little
analysis but with a billion things to do
it's also the future me the six months
later me that pops open the markdown
document and goes
all right i'm good because i've got my
code
i've got the explanation i can see the
outputs i've
even got text that explains what i was
thinking
hurrah right but here's another
audience for your for your reports it
could be a quantitative colleague
who wants to see code who wants to see
data who wants to see your assumptions
who wants to dig into you know your your
residual plots from your model
i can guarantee you the non-quantitative
people won't want to see that
so it's good if you can try to balance
up and try to have
techniques that would allow you to hide
the bits that the non-quantitative
people
want to see but also allow the
quantitative people to get what they
want from that report
so back to notebooks just for a second i
realize
and again thank you that there is a
debate here
but for analysis if your writing
analysis i think notebooks are fantastic
and back to garrett's stuff about
markdown
in if you're writing more code sorry
writing more comments than code
then you should be using our markdown in
notebooks if you're using writing more
code than comments
write more comments and use our markdown
but
if you're not writing for analysis then
i really recommend you go and read this
blog post because it's
it's very interesting also
because i'm lazy i knew my manager would
come back and ask for the same analysis
across the three endpoints that are in
my data okay
so i'm trying to set up my report to
answer
quantitative non-quantitative and for
three different endpoints
paste your code more than three times
what should you do
write a function if you have to perform
an analysis across more than three
endpoints
what do you do do you write multiple
hour markdown
reports parameters reports thanks very
much otherwise why would you be here i
mean honestly
i'm not that entertaining anyway back to
xkcd
um xkcd talks about automation
and the top panel talks about the theory
of automation it's a bit like the theory
of data science
it's the mental model for what we all
hope will happen
we automate things we can get on and we
can do completely different work
the reality is that when you automate
things and try to be clever often you
wind up
troubleshooting the thing that's gone
wrong
but here's here's the thing that makes
all of this work is the yaml header
parameters now if
if you're familiar with our markdown
then you'll know about the yaml header
if you're not familiar with our markdown
um this
may be a bit of a stretch but bear with
me okay so the yaml
header says something about the document
it says the title the author the date it
was done
and it says something about the
formatting for the output so here it's
an html document and it has some
certain attributes the bit of
highlighted in red is the bit we need to
focus on
right these are parameters that you can
pass into your document
and it comes into your document um you
know like an r
object that you can then use you can
compute on you can do all kinds of
clever things with it
so here in my document in my head header
i've got a parameter which is called
endpoint
it has a default value of hamdi tl17
but it also has three distinct choices
so you
it's not just a free text you have to
choose one of those three options
also i've got a boolean parameter which
is called quantitative audience and if
that is true
then i'm going to include a bunch of
other stuff but if it's false
then this is the strip back report just
for the non-quantitative audience
okay now the
the specification of those is very close
to what you might do with with shiny
inputs if you're familiar with them
so then when you're ready you can choose
to knit that document and if you just
hit the nip button
you'll get the default values but if you
can choose to knit with parameters
then a little pop-up box comes up a bit
like shiny
you choose your endpoints you determine
whether you're in the quantitative
audience
and you can knit your document now
parameters are really cool because
you can do things with them so here i've
embedded
the parameter endpoint or its param
dollar
endpoint and that value can get pasted
into text
so then you can talk about the end point
for the report that you're talking about
you can use the the uh pass the
parameter in and use it within the
markdown text
you can use it as a in the header or the
access labels for the ggplot
and so it's it can be used in a variety
of ways sky's the limit
okay but the other thing that's kind of
cool
is that you can use the parameters in
determination of whether the code chunk
runs or not
so here i'm saying if it's not the
quantitative audience
in other words if it's the
non-quantitative audience then hide all
the code
right the other thing that makes this
work is in the top box and that's
because what i did was to rename
all of the endpoint columns in my data
with the name of the parameter endpoint
so that then downstream
i can you know fit a linear model on
something called outcome
and not on something called param dollar
endpoint okay it just
cleans up the code and it makes things
easier to see further down
you can choose to run code chunks
at all based on on parameters
the other thing that i've used is a
child document because if you remember
when i'm
presenting this to the quantitative
audience i want to pull in some extra
information
the code chunks will run or not
according to the the settings here
but you might want some additional bit
of text that comes in and says okay for
the quantitative guys here's what i'm
doing
uh and that's where the child document
comes in they're just plain text
or markdown files and those guys get
pulled in
if needed so for the quantitative
audience what you see here
is that we're showing the code i've run
the chunk
you can see the data and the bit at the
bottom that says data manipulations
is that child document text now if
you're
tariff kind of stole some of my thunder
uh in his opening talk but that's okay
he's the president that's fine
uh what you can do in our studio connect
is that you can go across to the left
hand side where it says input you can
pop that open and it will have the same
ability to select
parameters and define what the report is
going to run
but the other nice thing is that if you
do that and you save those things as
named objects
then in our studio connect you've just
got this little drop down menu
of pre-compiled reports so what you
might want to do
is to set up you know commonly used
here it was all right because there's
only six reports
in total that could be done but it's
it's that ability that if someone has
already run this report you can just
quickly grab it and it doesn't have to
recompile
okay so more about parameterization
so what we saw was when we render the
the report
um it you go to the render with
parameters or knit with parameters
but from the command line you can pass
in your parameters
just through a list like this okay and
it's it's really straightforward
um the second thing is you might want to
change your analysis depending on which
endpoint you're looking at if you're
looking at a
categorical outcome you're not going to
want a linear model
or at least you shouldn't um so in that
that case you may want to tailor your
analysis depending on the parameter
endpoint but again it's just
you know another thing that you can
compute on within a chunk
also if something goes wrong with your
analysis
then if you're handling the error
appropriately if you're using try catch
or something like that
you can compute on that and then have a
child document that says something
helpful like
you know something's gone wrong contact
your friendly data scientist
you know here's his details okay
so the other last thing back to xkcd
is how long should you spend
parameterizing your report
and setting things up now this is kind
of alarming
i know that jd long has also talked to
this this graph
uh today but the uh thing i want to
impress on you is basically
you know this is over five years so
you know if you spend a day or two days
or five days sorting this out
then uh and only two people are going to
use it once every six months
maybe i wasted my time but on the other
hand i got a conference talk out of it
so that's good
anyway thank you very much for your
attention uh feel free to ask questions
[Applause]
all right thank you very much mike we
have time for questions before the break
for lunch hands please
okay can i ask one myself
so you're building all of this wonderful
machinery
and then you move on and somebody else
has to maintain it how many of the
people that you work with
understand and value the machinery that
you've just shown us
oh well that's a tricky question
not many at present and how are you
tackling that
well i've just done the train the
trainer on the tidy verse and i'm here
so i'm going to go back and evangelize
and
you know um but yes it's a problem that
we need to try to
roll this out and get more and more
people familiar with how it works
[Music]